kazim direct à la plage monsieur du snob
est à la pêche avec le facteur
françois et tentera de les cibles wiki
après le lait ça n'est pas malade tu
m'as fait par g je me croyais tout seul
chez soi je suis navré ça va maintenant
tu es remise de ses émotions à peu près
et dit moi je croyais que tu étais en
train de l'estivé mon kiosque oui
justement mais je sais pas où est la
lessive impossible de mettre la main
dessus mais les dents dans la boîte sur
laquelle est inscrite caramels mous ah
bon ben oui évidemment je réduis pensais
ça ça tombe sous le sens au revoir au
revoir il est parti le pauvre il en a au
moins jusqu'à ce soir
bauer dépêche ah oui ce grand cru de
léona répand dormi au fond de son
repaire et je suis enfin seul avec ce
livre que je voudrais lire depuis une
semaine
[Musique]
maintenant
je viens d'en jacca concours cette
sieste
dis-moi léonard tu crois pas que ça te
ferait du bien de dormir encore un peu
si tu crois que ça m'amuse d'être obligé
de faire la conversation pourquoi tu ne
t'ennuies prend mais non lui pas de toit
à gènes l'éducation
si vous croyez que c'est facile de lire
dans ces conditions là bon alors de quoi
veux tu que nous parle bon d'un tout le
match des habitants de l'île aux enfants
par exemple c'est pas très très
intéressant mais faute de mieux vous
écoute les uns à rejeter tout raconter
sur eux tu les connais tous à tous près
tout ce qu'on m'a parlé d'un certain
merlot paul machy je crois un détective
j'aimerais bien faire sa connaissance
mais lui ne se déplace que lorsqu'il ya
une enquête à faire oui mais pour en
trouver quelque chose qui a disparu
oui exactement et rien n'a disparu
si quelques chances disparaît ses
agents comprend cool
julich encore toi non mais c'est pas ma
faute je sais pas où est la brosse à
chiendent mais elle est dans la boîte
étiquetée farine ah oui et où se trouve
la farine dans la boîte marqué gros sel
voyons le principal c'est que du tir
trop
dis-moi léonard ça ne produit pas que
nous interrogions notre conversation
parce que j'aimerais bien lire mon livre
un peu
mou et ils ont fait ça je l'avais posé
là
je comprends léonard en moi mouly qu'il
livre je n'ai pas vu livre moi vous avez
vu un livre vous avez annie leonard ne
fait pas l'innocent je ne sais
absolument pas de quoi tu veux parler
léonard je sais que tu as pris mon livre
faible alors des princes j'exige des
princes c'est moi je venais pas eh bien
si c'est comme ça moi je vais chercher
monsieur marc foltz c'est une très bonne
idée
[Musique]
ans
que personne ne sorte
que personne ni à un créneau plus que
mort mais il n'y a personne dans ce
ravisseur cat
et moi je compte en double à
27,6 pas le de beurre ni j'adore lite
host avec un beau but clos tanière aux
exclus aux nuits malade je ne vous avais
pas vus vous êtes s'est petit à
petit
chemin jure 53 cm - cieux montchamp qui
ont faim et je suis me life and death du
type diplômés de scotland yard
monsieur léonard j'irai tout raté au but
sans aucun détour
le livre de mademoiselle julie que
chamotte gracieuse bouclé a disparu je
connaître une phase coupable c'est vous
alors vous avouez vous réglez le livre à
moi et nous n'ont pas non plus il vole à
une affaire de plus du cloud
je suis innocent là ce sera vérité c'est
un bon gamin me sur le 1er mai mais vous
étiez tout seul avec ma muse est jolie
qui d'autre aurait pu subtiliser le
livre
c'est pas moi
franchement
non non monsieur l'airial ce n'est pas
un frein soit si ce que françois je le
serai puisque
ce léonard manière sincère ça c'est une
des enquêtes les plus en mêlée qui me
soient tombés sous la loupe alors
monsieur meilleure forme ce sacripant de
léonard est il passé aux aveux
non pas encore mais je suis sur une
piste oui mais ça ne va nulle tard je
vous en prie je vous en plus c'est ma
nouvelle tuerie vous étiez assise là sur
cette chaise parfaitement ce sac et
qu'ils votent oui
mais nous est jolie
qu'y at-il dans le tri c'est qu'ils
repèrent mon porte-monnaie des
provisions
mûri
france alors que
vous allez lire à voix haute et claire
le texte complet de cette histoire a les
honneurs
c'est n'est que le début de l'histoire
il ya encore quatre livres comme ça qui
suivent ça va j'ai tout le temps
alosi mademoiselle julie voyous
il était une fois